creator consciousness
everyone wants to express themselves
at their absolute fullest potential
leading into 2021 we want to
architect a more abundant and prosperous
future for everyone
let's break down the steps at how to
most efficiently achieve said goal
the first and most important thing to
take away from this
is that this is not spiritual
woo this is scientifically
empirically validated
that the psychological literature is
extremely
clear that the more that you hone in
on future authoring
achieving some sort of divine noble
transcendent aim
that the healthier happier and more
fulfilled the more meaning you'll find
every single day
and this is the exact opposite of victim
consciousness
this is the exact polar opposite
every day to re-baseline ourselves more
and more
like we're working out away from victim
consciousness and more and more towards
this
creator consciousness
that my simple thinking
around wanting to manifest a more
abundant
and prosperous future
is enough to slowly work my way
into a more healthy well-being
on a day-to-day basis on a very
pragmatic
scientific level decreasing your
cortisol
increasing your states
of causeless joy and
imperturbable peace cellular equanimity
this is paramount for 2021
and beyond for creator consciousness to
really anchor itself
in our society for it to achieve its
fullest potential
especially as we experience more and
more of the de-sacralization
of our lives due to what appears to be a
very
modern economic machinery that's
treating people like they're just
cogs in some sort of a machine that
doesn't respect their sovereignty
doesn't respect their freedom it doesn't
respect their artistic divine
noble transcendent north star and
purpose
that they are divinely here to do
we must take a step back from that
we must divinely pursue
truth we must divinely pursue our north
star
with the same amount of vigor that we
pursue
breathing
the same amount that you want to breathe
your next inhale
you should want to achieve your
most divine fullest potential in the
world so take a step back
and recalibrate and figure out how to
future author that for yourself
and this is why there is such a massive
proliferation
of the quote self-help gurus and coaches
in modernity especially
there is a victim consciousness that
doesn't know how to actualize a
transcendent noble aim
and so it identifies a creator
consciousness
and then it goes to its guru teachings
or
coachings seminars
and obtains said wisdoms
and then re-baselines itself
doing the reps doing the workout away
from
victim consciousness towards creator
consciousness
these people are very important and they
deeply serve
the dissemination of creator
consciousness awakening
to other
people that are
in a more contracted state of being that
need to express themselves as the gods
that they are
and that they pierce that veil and
recognize that
and then unleash themselves
so the scientific validation is critical
and it's a beautiful place where
spirituality and science synthesize
all right the manifestation mechanics
number two
what is a good
protocol for parsing
to find what you think is
a good amount of signal around creator
consciousness
well whatever
makes you feel more sovereign
more like the supreme divine authority
that you
are as well as free freedom
from moment to moment whatever makes you
feel
less suffering less pain less depression
and more sovereignty and more freedom
and more well-being and more prosperity
and more abundance
that is signal follow that signal
seek that signal
like it's your full-time job
take it in take it in have it become
you have creator consciousness
sit in your soul in order for
manifestation mechanics to
fully be optimized and this means
for those that are experiencing these
deep
profound states of suffering and pain
and depression and anxiety and turmoils
of all sorts
learn that the reason why you are
experiencing that is because you are in
a contracted state of being
you do not recognize your own infinitude
you do not
recognize your own god-ness
and because of that what's happening is
you're in a contracted state in a
limited perspective
and so in order to get yourself out of
that contracted state
out of that limited perspective you have
to do these reps
in order to become a manifestation
machine in order to
have creator consciousness in 2021 and
beyond
so these reps are doing things like
actualizing the pause the pause is
one of the largest most
important perennial spiritual wisdoms
across the entire planet in meditation
you have to create a pause use the
mechanism of your breath
to create a pause if you're depressed if
you're contracted
use the breath gather another
perspective gather a perspective about
about health about prosperity about
goodness about things that serve you
rather than things that don't that
negativity so you can
catch yourself moving from moment to
moment into a depressive state
create a pause and redirect your
attention and focus
to something that's positive that serves
you and that's what's going to enable
you to manifest
that right there is manifestation that
pause
and then manifesting positivity instead
of negativity
is a really critical repetition
towards manifestation towards the
mechanics that are going to enable you
to achieve even more
divine transcendent north stars
and that's what is god consciousness
versus limited enslavement
that tiny perspective of suffering
and depression versus
the full unleashing of your divine
godness into the world
you are here to do that you are here to
express yourself
as god as the infinitude that we
are you are not here to live in a
contracted
depressed and deprived state of being
although that suffering serves us as a
drill sergeant to awakening
and that's the bliss the peace the
eternity the infinity that
await us when we anchor those
manifestation mechanics on a
moment-to-moment basis with creator
consciousness
oh how good does it feel every day
every moment to be coming from that
place
of one infinite creator expressing
itself
and you being that you are that we
are that and to know that on a
moment-to-moment basis
is bliss it is
peace it is love
the recognition that we share that one
infinite creator
all right so you may also wonder okay so
sure
now we have the scientific validation
done we have these manifestation
mechanics down
so what would this north star be well
there are really good places to start
first of all exposure
we need as conscious parents to expose
children to the massive buffet of
options
and then we have to do this montessori
style method where we
follow the child's interests because
that is what's going to give us the most
clear signal of what their north star
truly is
and typically we want to understand that
the more that we provide a north star to
civilization that is
in value to sieve providing
value being sto which means
service to other less
service to self self dealing
i want more for myself conspicuous
consumption
materialism sex drugs
all of those more primal
versus the more service to other the
more
god-like moral highest that we channel
through
us into the world which inevitably
brings us
more flourishing well-being prosperity
everything by being in service to others
another way to view it is sdgs the
sustainable development goals
we want to eradicate poverty we want to
eradicate
suffering we want to provide people
around the world with quality education
especially regarding self-realization as
well as self-actualization
we want to provide people with clean
water and sanitation
we want to provide people with
affordable and clean energy
we want to keep a very healthy
sustainable
growing pie for everyone around the
planet
so the sdgs are a really great place
to look as well in general we want to
remove the molasses we want to remove
the friction we want to meet the basic
needs of people worldwide to enable
everyone to actualize their fullest
potential
and we have to undergo this process
of making those incremental steps
because manifestation works optimally
when we architect the next steps
but we have to have no attachment in
that process
so that's the thing with these
manifestation mechanics with your north
star
you absolutely have to do some future
authoring regarding
okay so what i'm feeling today is i'm
feeling like i want to create this
creator consciousness video
and so i actually had to go through the
process
of writing out these points these four
points
and writing out the key subpoints and i
had to undergo this process
and it took me a while to do this today
to get ready to do this stream
but i can't just say i want to make a
video on creator consciousness and then
just undergo a process of
watching netflix bruh
that's not how manifestation mechanics
work
manifestation mechanics work when you
actually take the next steps that are
needed
on a day-to-day week-to-week
month-to-month
and year-to-year basis to get to those
defined
transcendent noble aim north stars
but we don't have attachment we're very
flexible
on the journey that flexibility is a lot
like a bayesian cloud of probabilities
that exist in this tree of possibility
towards that north star which we
which we write about in high level
perception
so no attachment yet having future
authoring
and architecting that step by step
and number four wisdom this
is critical this is happening around the
planet
to so many people that are experiencing
creator levels of consciousness
is what happens is egoic levels
of consciousness end up
creeping into your
psyche and pulling you down so
we have to key word here key word under
wisdom
is the word grace we have to
gracefully separate ourselves from
people who don't serve the highest
and this means family you're going to
have
family that's 25 sometimes 30 years
older than you and their consciousness
is just
a lot more constricted at times
especially when they're not a conscious
parent
and what's going to happen is if they've
never tasted non-duality
if they've never tasted the unity of all
being in existence if they've never
tasted the infinity
if they've never even tasted the pause
in meditation and they're just
a reactive monkey-mind creature to their
external world they have
victim consciousness no creator
consciousness you have to distance
yourself
you have to create that separation same
goes for your friends
the same goes for your co-workers the
same goes for people on the internet
hurt people hurt other people
that's why every single internet comment
that you see that's bullying someone
else
is from someone else that is hurt
and they see you in a state of
flourishing and they're trying to pull
you down
separate yourself gracefully separate
yourself
create the pause again the space
see that analogy is beautiful you create
that pause that space
and then you continue architecting
and undergoing this divine transcendent
north star
and the manifestation mechanics and
creator consciousness
that entails this process and over time
what happens is naturally naturally
you are going to attract
both
co-creators that are
manifesters themselves as well as
co-creators that have undergone
non-dual awareness and it's really going
to accelerate your creator consciousness
to the next level to surround yourself
with those co-creators
but you have to create that space you
have to gracefully separate yourself
to create enough space for you to have
new co-creators
that come into your life that have
experienced non-duality
that have experienced the manifestation
mechanics
around the creator consciousness
and this is where we're going we're
heading towards an enlightened
civilization
mwah as our north star collectively
and this means clean and pure mirrors
of the one infinite creator
this means that we recognize the fact
that
we have a state of non-dual awareness
we've recognized our infinitude we've
recognized the fact that our awareness
is collectively shared and we've peeled
back those
onion layers of identity away from
all of the insane associations that
we've taken on with that separate
self-consciousness
and we've identified ourselves as god
as that shared god as that shared source
and that it's expressing itself and that
we recognize that we have a unique
expression to bring of that god
of that source and we're all acting as
divine mirrors for one another that are
clean mirrors
we are acting towards the acceleration
of each other's fullest artistic
expression
fullest true self-realization and
self-actualization
that is what an enlightened civilization
is that is where we can go with our
creator consciousness in 2021 and beyond
but we have to truly communicate the
profundity of the scientific literature
the eradication of suffering the
development of that meditative pause
that enables us to have the
manifestation mechanics towards
something that's more positive something
that's more divine and transcendent
towards that north star
make those north stars around tackling
some of the biggest challenges on the
planet bringing value to civilization's
awakening
and then wisely we'll draw more and more
of the co-creators into our lives and
distance ourselves more and more
from consciousness that is not in
service to that and then we'll
uplift the rising tide will lift all
boats towards that
enlightened civilization of the one
infinite creator
fully expressing itself through us we
are god
we are source expressing itself
eternally
infinitely we've been doing it we're
gonna keep doing it
wake up to that faster get yourself out
of the suffering
into a state of being a god-like being
that you
are i love you very much
thank you for tuning in would love to
hear your thoughts
in the comments below on creator
consciousness and the
mechanics that go into this process
where you're at let me know i'd love to
help out
like the video share the video with
other people subscribe if you haven't
get
other people around the world more
excited about
creator consciousness in 2021 and beyond
architecting that more beautiful
abundant prosperous future that we all
know is possible
and go and do that do those next steps
make 2021 that such a beautiful
exceptional year
for you and for all of us adore you
thank you for being here fam
love you talk to you soon